all right euro now that the Cleveland
woman who dropped a two-year-old in the
cheetah pit at the zoo has been punished
with a leave of absence from her job at
the daycare center someone has to tell
me what you've got to do over there to
get fired
put twins in the wood chipper I you know
I I get presumed innocent but with that
kind of job security you should be a cop
Durrell North Korean textbook scan
claimed Kim jong-un writes musicals won
or yacht race in grade school and
learned to drive when he was three but
they can't claim this is his picture I
mean I don't like kids and I hate
dictators but this is a door I'm not
even starving in North Korean I want to
eat him up
and driving at 3:00 that's a very young
age to learn to not signal neural if you
spent any time at all this week
arguing whether the cat in this viral
photo is coming up the steps or going
down the steps you miss the bigger
question how come the cat gets nine
lives and you don't even have one new
role the Fox News host who said Hillary
Clinton ate at Chipotle to appeal to
Hispanic voters must answer me this
where is she supposed to eat if she goes
to chick-fil-a they'll claim she's
flip-flopped on gay marriage Panda
Express she's not being tough enough in
China Dunkin Donuts sympathizing with
violent cops Dairy Queen sounds too much
like welfare queen and thanks to her
husband forget about going to in and out
you know somebody needs to tell this
Corinne guy singing about how much he
loves a big booty that he's in the wrong
country you call that a booty we have
toddlers with more junk in the trunk you
want to see a booty go to a Walmart on
Saturday we'll hook you up